ciao al quinto come siete mai chiesti
qualche cosa perché questo chiederle
come mai che cosa ha fatto questa è una
delle abitazioni più importanti e credo
che stia nella nostra città che anche
per tutti e fino a quando non so non ho
compreso proprio molto bene che non
esiste casualità ma esiste causa cioè le
cose non succedono mai a caso
ma succede sempre come effetto di
qualche causa che abbiamo messo faccia
diverse quando ho voluto bene e perfetto
un problema nasce quando le cose che gli
italiani non ci piacciono molto allora
pensiamo sempre che questo effetto
dipende da qualcun altro
non è vero tutto dipende dalle cause che
non riusciamo a mettere quindi se
dedizione la casualità siamo oggetti
della vita
se invece funziona latte
casualità fonia che militiamo soggetti
della nostra vita
noi determiniamo o perlomeno possiamo
determinare quelle sedi territoriali che
subiremo di tutto dipende questo mentre
se può sembrare banale ma è
importantissimo perché vuol dire che se
noi comprendiamo questa cosa e poi
l'asta di vediamo che la mettiamo in
pratica e questo è il problema più
importante peccato il m solo teoria ma
se noi come grandi in pratica sceglie le
fonti che sei anni adroni della nostra
vita che non è male quindi le mie o nel
male
questo è un effetto che abbiamo c'è una
frana pubblica che a me piace molto che
dice se vuoi sapere perchè degli esteri
che in questo momento
guarda le cause che mi sono il passato
ma se tu vuoi sapere che gli esterni che
vale nella lista cultura
guarda il caso che mettevo i problemi
personalmente consiglio a tutti di
guardarsi il cavo dune passato ma è
molto meglio vogliamo recava
il presente perché lui possa non ci
possiamo tornare che il video effetti
sangue intendo releghiamo qui da questo
momento in avanti possiamo diventare
allora la nostra vita
qui ci piace che non ci piace però può
essere fantastico patio del termine ma
nello stesso tempo e nel senso di
responsabilità perché non posso dare a
cuba nessun altro sono io che le terne
colate siamo noi non solo sarà noi che
determiniamo quello che vorremmo avere
una vita e se uno questa cosa invece a
interiorizzare molto bene se accorge
invece veramente una capsula fantastica
non solo riesce
conosciamo tutti noi a dare alla nostra
dignità
un valore incredibile perché un conto è
essere soggetto delle galline di lugo
oggetto poté successo questo il testo
non lo so cappello è successo ma serve
invece determinato fondamento quello che
vogliamo e lo spoglio inviamo che quando
sarà già vogliamo che funziona
pensate che valore ha la verità quindi
noi siamo alla vita e questo e quindi
altrimenti
mi annoiero all'album è tradizionalmente
che mostra una torino tanto povero il
figlio sono stati di particolare non
sono brevi che c'erano delle cose
formina limitavo nella mia vita
posso dire derive assunto tramite molto
intensamente
potrei anche dire che ho vissuto la
merita almeno su due o tre volte in
questa lista lavorativa affettiva di suv
miliare nel verde media eccetera perché
perché da sempre
successivamente hanno imparato ha capito
perché ma anche lo 3 ma gli orsetti
costantemente fatto delle scelte e sono
sempre stato responsabile
quindi quando a 11 anni mi è stato detto
che se volevo studiare devo studiare
altrimenti il loro anno ad adorare di un
po scelto di una morale
quindi all 11 anni perché la pena perché
c'era freddo per per sporcare ma per me
la scuola e alla dura prigione quindi
ora felicissimo quindi è una scelta che
ho fatto poi che è caso che volete
incontro delle console comincia a
studiare scorsa quindi bravo lo faccio
le scuole serali
qui comincia a raddoppiare la verità
lavoravano studiamo misera benissimo non
solo ti diamo poi ho cambiato anche loro
ho cominciato fra i progetti e 16 anni
mi sono trovato a 21 anni che sembra che
le mie scelte non c'è ne sono felice
santi biglietti via mare aveva detto
insiste regalassero lanificio pubblico
così o si tornò e mi senti o no ti
voglio fare qualcosa di diverso
quindi io ho fatto progetti arrivi un
anni 80 la ufficio per punto io il
perchè momento ha per la città siamo
prestazione e il turn over e non sono
eccezionali su una persona comune ma
certamente molto
tutte queste mie decisivo in queste mi
nazioni mi hanno portato constantemente
a cambiare vita
quindi ad essere veramente padrone non
so se quindi deciso di fare una società
d'ingegneria ho fatto progetti che
ancora adesso uni mia valigia tour
definizione ma non credo e alluvioni in
fatto di predicare impossibile che deve
solamente perché ne devono andare
qui la situazione perchè ha determinato
che qui lavoro sei stato capace di fare
quando mi devi fare tu metti che avevo
mai fatto l'ho trovato promettendo però
mi sento di fare bene
allora ho fatto anche quello quando si è
trattato di due benefici gente che
settore militare
ce la faranno stabilimenti di canada il
mio inglese era esattamente buongiorno e
buonasera ho deciso di farlo stabiliti
camera
ho lavorato per sei anni
mi ha coinvolto nella gestione e per sei
anni facevo per stimare in italia e per
settimane perdere quasi trenitalia
facevo questo progetto per settimane la
facevo così di colpo è morto ha detto
bellissimo fantastico non è una bambina
non è nessuno all'interno ha mai pesante
io non ne sono mai reso conto che la
cosa forse espresa lite perché mi
piaceva che pesa di nuovo completamente
quindi non è che tutti pensassero e
provassero a fare presto non fra
diminuito quell'unico postato chiamiamo
per la nostra felicità per i successi
della nostra vita siamo noi se io metto
le card le grosse di giulio star
dell'incontro non sanno mai di me quindi
sarò io scusate ho semplicemente
aggiorna vorrei che fosse tutti
tutti noi possiamo fare tutto possiamo
fare tutto basta siano terminati se non
siamo determinati e inseriti pensiamo
che io non lo merito io non ci riuscirò
mai è troppo grande
non vorremmo mai che ci mancano sempre
stato da quindi alla fine della notte
dei fatti il mio arriveremo così
reimpianto miglior aver fatto delle cose
per poter ieri il nome di menti dei
rimpianti certo fa tutto quello che se
proprio vi vede che se meriterà lo fa
verità
questo è veramente molte foto una cosa
tipo frange di un oncologo qanto
riguarda la parte sedimentare la pausa
dal lavoro ma parlando col sentimentale
è stato stretto rispetto che sono brad
pitt ha avuto delle reazioni un nuovo
lunghe con donne molto belle miss alle
50 e la vendono specchia dalla
cosiddetta che è perché si dice del
resto cosa senza melo dovevano non so se
mi sono spiegato
io ho fatto quei versioni che portavano
canzoni telefoni succedesse non mi
sorridono misseri
quindi a comando remoto quindi sono
tutto questo ha portato a votare sì che
io a 40 anni con queste presente alle
spalle non ho mai chiesto a nessuno di
sposarvi non ho mai assolutamente
pensate a scovarne bene a 30 anni ei
punto una persona per tre volte loro
rose di lavoro la terza volta e dico di
sì sarà del matrimonio entro dicembre
e questo può sembrare la regione corre
nola che non casualità e causalità
perché io comunque conosce non avrei
voluto che è esattamente la conosce 16
di conseguenza ci siamo sposati veri i
seriani matrimonio senza mari apicali
delle cose più belle che i suns corato
in veloce per seguire una cosa molto
bella regata la vita purtroppo siamo
abituati a considerare sempre
nasco muore è un periodo di tempo
bene cromata che pensare in terminare
questa nuova tutte in continuare allora
ecco infatti sulla mia tomba o già
campionato delle meritarsi che è molto
sentito
con lo subito